what is up everyone happy monday super
excited for this new stream idea episode
one of the gratitude journal so one of
the things i do with the senior people
on my team is we have a private facebook
group and every day during the week the
least we post three things that were
grateful for and then I make them due to
other things as well and if you look at
any study unhappiness you'll find that
gratefulness is always a key component
of it it's really hard to be angry or to
be sad if we depressed or get their own
when you're also grateful for the things
that that are around you and I think
it's entrepreneurs you don't necessarily
have enough gratitude in our life and so
we've we've had a lot of success in our
own little private Facebook group and I
thought why don't why not bring this to
believe nation to why not how this is
something that everybody can benefit
from and enjoy in as well and so what I
thought is this new stream 9 a.m.
eastern where I share three things that
I'm grateful for and then also encourage
you guys to in the comments share what
you're grateful for for the day and I'm
going to read some of them out loud for
10 minutes that's it and move on to the
rest of our days I got a live stream on
League coming up right after with rishi
Cup TV so for me three things that I'm
grateful for and while I'm saying this
guy's for those watching live leave it
leave your thoughts in the comments what
you're grateful for the day and then for
you watching you guys watching
afterwards not the live leave it in the
comments and if you get into that habit
of leaving three things you big before
you'll find that you're much happier
entrepreneur and we need happy
entrepreneurs to go out and change the
world so one of the things that I've
also found really important before
getting the mine is you got to feel it
too right not just listening out that I
before my wife and my kids and my city
and whatever right but actually feeling
it while you are expressing it because
that makes a big difference so for me
I'm grateful that I get to see the CN
Tower every day I'm sitting here at my
off
is in Toronto and city and I design my
space so that I can see the CN Tower
every day I'd one of the tallest
structures in the world and gives me
motivation every day to see what great
things people have built and I want to
go and build mine just like these people
behind me um I'm grateful for the
constant support and never-ending love
of my wife yesterday was a long day we
had the kids over my niece and nephew
and it ended up being an amazing day but
like a long day I had to go to TDS
afterwards had some meetings and get
back to the late a Nina's support
through everything really helps me keep
doing uh what I do and so I really
appreciate that and the third thing I
would say that I'm grateful for today is
is the energy and smile of my son Hayden
uh seemingly boundless energy and
enjoyment and love and every time I
think for you guys to you when you're
around kids you see them come alive it
gives you energy and so I'm just
thinking of a smile right now in his
life and his excitement his energy and
that that that fills me up and so those
are the three things that I am grateful
for for today Monday September 12th
leave yours in the comments live chat
we've got six minutes left I'm going to
read some L give you guys some shoutouts
let's see what's up first up so for
business kind of questions this is not a
business question stream I'm going to be
on in after this immediately six minutes
go to the twitch stream Rishi Cup TV and
I are going to be answering business
questions while I play game a league so
I should be fun and interesting this is
just about gratitude so Lynette I'm
grateful for life this morning and the
ability to change my circumstances I
love that one a lot of people don't take
responsibility for their life in their
situation and you have the ability to
change your circumstances to choose my
state of mind and how
to spend this gift of another day here
on earth I love it Lynette Lynette Lou
is standing up they know I'm not in the
right state of mind to really be
grateful right now too furious and sad
let me just be grateful for this live
stream then that's an interesting ones i
know and i know you're you know usually
super positive and your big part of this
community and i say there's more kind of
chats down there below one of the things
again that i found that i mention at the
top is it's really hard to be sad and
depressed and furious when you're also
grateful when you think about you know
how you're fortunate in life when you
think about your situation and how you
already have way more than most people
in the world uh and so it can be okay to
be furious and give me sad and I'm you
know sorry for whatever happened and
kind of curious to find out but in the
grand scheme of things is it really that
big a deal right like you're still young
you still have your health you still
have you no internet access there's a
lot to be grateful for um but thank you
for sharing and even that little bit
even a little bit as a step right let me
just be grateful for this live stream
then even that I know it's a small thing
in a bigger world but even a little bit
of hope recognize a little bit of
gratitude makes things a little bit
easier J reyez grateful for YouTube
which allows so much awesome creations
people for internet which connects us
all grateful for Evan who's experiments
and host these events appreciate the
love j reyez gr eyes is going to be on
the livestream the league live stream to
in four minutes um yeah it's it's one of
the things that I try to do with the
team two is encourage them to be
grateful for things that are not always
super obvious like I'm grateful for you
too that may seem like a stupid thing
but it is like YouTube has allowed me to
be to do what I do like I wish YouTube
was around I was just getting started
the things that I could have learned the
pace that I could have been at is crazy
and so to think about the availability
and accessibility of resources that we
have that we didn't have before you know
there's no excuse there's no excuse for
not going
getting yours and forcing you don't have
you know access to mentors and
information it's never been easier and
so I'm right with Jay rise in this one
too Rishi kept TV my co-host in three
minutes grateful for fall in particular
p psl season I don't know what psl
season is but I'm curious to find out to
my house last week when nauseous with
flu I was once again reminded this great
blessing of health amazing and three my
parents who have always believed in me I
love it too and and I'm right there with
you my parents this is me when I'm like
seven or eight and my parents and
believe came from them so I'm superb you
[ __ ] super super appreciative that's
grateful and appreciative at the same
time is agree shutov we've just created
a new word here i J guys also been
prefer shelter and a stable environment
to participate from Rishi is vehicle for
Zeno great list i agree man keep it
coming keep it coming grateful for free
flowing food drink air ideas and support
grateful for YouTube ad revenue I love
that hey you know what it's good it's
good to be grateful hey Zeno's back
grateful for james naismith for
inventing basketball they go man
hopefully feeling a little bit better
throughout this dream because you think
about james naismith inventing
basketball I believe his Canadian I
believe that's the Canadian thing I mean
Canadian pride right there baseball fan
but let's just look that up James
Naismith I'm pretty sure he's canadian
canadian american physical educator epic
he was born where is he born Almonte or
that is I think it's Canada yes ontario
canada i love it canada standing up next
keep it coming guys what do we got what
we got how can i get youtubers to join
my fila program business questions in
one minute on the League of Legends
stream coming up what else what else
what else what else hey your confidence
in positivity is amazing
I appreciate that you people for that I
I appreciate that man I mean it takes it
takes a I wasn't always so confident and
I was pretty positive but I think like
that the more experience you get and the
more used to breaking through fears you
get the more confident you get in the
more positive you get at least for me
Rishi is grateful for the man beautiful
for the man who's the man all these
Rishi cup little things psl and the man
is interesting ah Vishwa enough
gratitude has made me look at people
differently I love that and that's it
guys nine ten happy Monday go out and
rock it go and destroy it I'm gonna jump
on the live stream if you follow me on
twitch you can have some business
questions we'll do this again tomorrow
9am Eastern whatever that time is where
you are continue to Brian believe or
whatever your one word is I'm a see you
soon